prophet abraham is a pivotal figure
in judaism christianity and islam
there's a lot of overlap in the stories
about
abraham in the quran and bible but it is
only the quran
that reveals knowledge about ancient
babylonia
that until recently has remained hidden
from mankind
lost in time
jewish christian and islamic sources all
place
abraham's birthplace in ancient
babylonia the region where we find
modern-day iraq this region worshiped
a multitude of gods and goddesses
of particular prominence in the pantheon
were celestial bodies
such as the stars and planets each city
had a patron god
which they worshipped as their main
benefactor and protector
the moon god nana symbolized by the
crescent was worshipped at ur
and haran shamash god of the sun
represented by the sola disc was
worshipped at larsa and
separa venus personified as the goddess
ishtar
was symbolized by an eight-pointed star
and worshiped
at uruk according to mesopotamian
mythology
these three celestial bodies the sun the
moon
and venus formed an astral triad
recent archaeological discoveries depict
the special relationship between these
deities
the stele of ur namu shows the sun and
moon
joined together the kuduru of king
malicipak
depicts the astral triad in full the
kaduru of nebuchadnezzar
shows the astral triad the stele of
nabonides
also depicts the astral triad the wide
geographic distribution of these
artifacts
indicates that this astral triad was a
prominent cult throughout the region
the quran informs us about some very
specific details
with regards to the idols that abraham's
people worshipped
[Music]
[Applause]
heather
[Music]
we can see the quran draws our attention
to their worship of the sun
moon and their third idol note the
details provided about the third idol
so when the knight covered him he saw a
star but when it said
he said i like not those that disappear
the word translated here as star is the
arabic word
kokab which carries the meaning of
celestial object
and can be used to refer to a star or
planet the quran tells us
that at the onset of nightfall this
celestial object
appeared for only a brief amount of time
this description of the third idol
matches the characteristics of the
goddess ishtar
one of her names was the evening star
because she personified venus
a planet that appears for only a brief
amount of time in the evening
we can see that the quran's claims about
the idolatry of abraham's people is
accurate
in light of what we know historically
about the cult of the astral triad
amazingly such knowledge of ancient
mesopotamian religion was lost for
thousands of years
it was recorded at temple sites such as
the famous ziggurat
of ore which was buried deep beneath the
desert sands
the temple was only rediscovered in the
early 20th century
thanks to the excavation efforts of
archaeologists such as
sir leonard woolley even the sumerian
language
that these ancient artifacts were
written in was unknown
it became a dead language around the
first century
forgotten until the mid 19th century in
light of these facts
how could muhammad peace and blessings
be upon him have accessed such knowledge
given that he lived in the seventh
century the only source of knowledge
about abraham that would have been
readily available
would have been the bible-based stories
and jewish legends in circulation
if we examine the bible we find that
it's silent on such details
long ago your ancestors including terah
the father of abraham and nahor
lived beyond euphrates river and
worshipped other gods we can see that it
makes no mention of specific idols that
were worshiped they are simply referred
to as
other gods regarding the jewish legends
that predate the quran
one of the stories found is as follows
and a voice came into his heart
saying all the signs of the stars and
the signs of the sun and moon
are all under the lord's control while
this account does reference
the sun and moon note how it mentions
stars
in the plural we can see that jewish
legend has a general awareness of their
worship of celestial objects
but it lacks the specifics of the astral
triad in the quran
in another jewish legend about abraham
we find mention of the worship of
elemental gods
behold the fire is more worthy of honor
than all things formed
but even more worthy of honor is the
water because it conquereth the fire
but even it i do not call god because it
is subjected to the earth
nowhere does the quran mention that
abraham's people worship the elements of
fire
water or earth now if the quran did copy
from such an account
then it would have included the mention
of these elements but it never does
these examples make it apparent that
jewish legends were also not used as
sources by the quran
now it's important to point out that
some of the deities did spread outside
the region
for example ishtar was also worshiped in
arabia
however she took on very different
characteristics
she became the male deity after
representing the god of thunderstorms
symbolized as an antelope in egypt she
was astarte
the goddess of war symbolized by a horse
and chariot
these incarnations are radically
different to their counterpart
ishtar the evening star
we can see that ishtar had a
chameleon-like quality
her identity was constantly evolving
with her attributes symbolism and even
gender differing from region to region
this would have made it difficult for
muhammad peace and blessings be upon him
to accurately pinpoint her identity in
the context of abraham
in conclusion the quran is filled with
stories about past nations
with its author consistently
demonstrating accurate knowledge of the
unseen
at different times and places in history
this is not a quality of human beings
but rather the divine the quran
proclaims that god almighty himself
revealed such knowledge
to learn more about the miracles of the
quran please download your free copy of
the book
the eternal challenge at the link below